[Música]
y comenzamos nuestra sección de revista
de prensa de hoy martes Ya está lista en
el estudio Rosa Pérez mateu Rosa
bienvenida Bueno mejor dicho bienvenido
yo que ya tenía unos días afuera de
nuestro programa Gracias Rosa vamos a
hablar entonces de la versión oficial de
kremlin reproducida por la televisión
Estatal rusa sobre los crímenes
ocurridos en bucha que supuestamente
según Rusia serían un montaje ucraniano
Buenos días Raúl exactamente Esto es lo
que está diciendo no el kremlin y vemos
muy claramente como se reproduce este
discurso en la televisión Estatal rusa
por lo que hemos querido seleccionar un
fragmento del cuidado del corresponsal y
Eugenia poodbunny que explica a los
periodistas que se encuentran sobre el
sobre el plató de la televisión Rusia 1
así como a los espectadores de este
canal ruso lo que él dice que ha pasado
incrustado con el ejército ruso en me
hace un reporte desde ahí si te parece
pues se lo escuchamos a continuación no
hemos podido seleccionar todo el
fragmento porque no teníamos tiempo pero
simplemente para ponerles en contexto
habla de que lo que sucedió en bucha es
canibalismo militar y un montaje
mediático veamos vamos en la pantalla de
la gente se mueve lo que significa que
había actores implicados Y por último
antes de que salieran los primeros
informes sobre esta producción
cinematográfica había vídeos de
propagandistas ucranianos de pucha y no
había cuerpos en las calles la
conclusión de todo esto es que para
conseguir sus objetivos mediáticos el
régimen ucraniano de kiev mató a su
propia gente
bien aquí vemos muy claramente no este
discurso en el que Rusia rechaza todas
las acusaciones y considera que es un
montaje hecho por kiev por selensky para
que pues el mundo se posicione si cabe
todavía más del lado ucraniano no pero
veamos los esfuerzos de distintos medios
de comunicación para desmentir esta
versión Así es rosa y como lo Entonces
lo tienen New York Times No él tiene
pues reportes imágenes satelitales
diciendo que pues todo esto ocurrió
muchísimo Antes de que se fueran las
tropas rusas no Rosa Exacto porque este
es el principal argumento del kremlin no
decir que los cadáveres empezaron a
aparecer después de que se retirara Pues
el último soldado ruso de la ciudad de
bucha el 30 de marzo sin embargo el New
York Times con imágenes satelitales de
maxar technologies está compañía que
también proporcionó las imágenes de
cuando Rusia estaba acumulando tanques
recordemos en la frontera con Ucrania
antes de la invasión bien con estas
imágenes satelita se ven cuerpos en las
calles de bucha mientras esta ciudad
estaba bajo ocupación rusa de hecho
vemos distintas imágenes en esta que
estamos viendo aquí vemos como los
cadáveres aparecen desde el 11 de marzo
a pesar de que esta imagen en concreto
sea del día 19 de este mes pasado por
otro lado también nos Explica el New
York Times que estas localizaciones que
vemos aquí son en las que encontraron
los cuerpos las fuerzas ucranianas
cuando llegaron a la ciudad no tras la
liberación Pues de este suburbio
ucraniano y aquí es lo que estamos
viendo cuando en esta imagen que es una
imagen de Instagram vemos en esta calle
Este cuerpo junto a estos dos
automóviles que corresponde con esta
imagen satelital del 21 de marzo y con
el cadáver ya en medio de la calle como
recordamos bajo la ocupación rusa no Y
para darles una idea de cómo trabaja el
equipo de investigaciones visuales del
en el siguiente vídeo vemos cómo
establece no esta correlación entre las
imágenes que salieron a la luz cuando
llegaron las tropas ucranianas a esta a
este suburbio y pues las imágenes
satelitales que han servido pues para
demostrar no que estos asesinatos fueron
cometidos pues bajo al menos en la
control ruso De esta zona Y si te parece
Raúl Vamos a continuar analizando los
puntos que van desmontando este discurso
oficial del kremlins Qué triste saber
esas imágenes Rosa vamos ahora con
eldiario.es en colaboración con [__]
que también desmontan Punto por punto
ese argumento de Moscú exactamente
porque como decíamos no este esta
retórica de que los crímenes Fueron
cometidos por Ucrania una vez se
retiraron las tropas rusas se cae
también desde otro ángulo Y es que como
Comenta Vanessa Rodríguez en este
artículo de [__] ya hay imágenes de
Pues a los cuerpos rusos en y los
cuerpos ucranianos bajo la ocupación
rusa el mismo uno de abril cuando según
medios de comunicación rusos la ciudad
todavía no estaba completamente libre no
de soldados rusos a pesar de que la
versión oficial del kremlin sea que se
retiraron el 30 de marzo por otro lado
también en este artículo dicen Rusia
Rusia dice que los cadáveres son una
puesta en escena y que pues no presentan
rigor mortis ni manchas ni entre otras
cosas mientras que la periodista dice
human right watch periodistas
internacionales y testigos no habitantes
del lugar documentan la masacre antes de
terminar Rosa vamos con la bbc que
desmiente estos supuestamente cadáveres
que se mueren que se mueven Perdón
Exacto porque esta es uno de los otros
argumentos del kremlin vemos
particularmente una imagen en la que
parece por un efecto óptico que se mueva
un cadáver que está tendido en el suelo
Aquí vemos a la derecha la imagen que se
ha publicado en redes sociales y a la
izquierda la imagen con analizada con
temperatura de donde lo que parece que
sea una mano que se mueve si vemos la
imagen pues grabada directamente en
vídeo cuando la analizamos vemos que lo
que se mueve en realidad no es el
cadáver sino una gota de lluvia o una
mancha del mismo parabrisas desde el que
se filma el propio pues vídeo y para
terminar Raúl belincat que también es de
los medios de comunicación de
investigación más importantes y que ha
sido citado tanto por la bbc como por
[__] acaba de publicar Hace unas
horas una imagen que parece ser del 3 de
marzo es decir también bajo ocupación
rusa Aquí vemos a los tanques rusos en
la ciudad y aquí dentro de esta redonda
roja vemos una persona en bicicleta que
es disparada por ese tanque aquí en esa
calle lo vemos ahí y eso corresponde con
un vídeo que acaban de publicar también
de un cadáver pues al lado de una
bicicleta encontrado por las fuerzas
ucranianas cuando llegaron a ducha bien
Este es un resumen un poco
de lo que se puede desmontar no de este
discurso del incremento de los
periodistas señalen que no se conocen
las causas de la muerte exactamente lo
que sí se puede constatar es que estas
muertes pues fueron cometidas bajo la
ocupación rusa de